I had a buddy who trained for years and
he couldn't grow his back and then he
and I did a back session together and he
was like I literally have never felt my
back my whole life until like this
session he'd been doing the volume but
he'd be doing it wrong the whole time
and that's where I like paying for
mentors the difference between having
active feedback with someone there who
knows how to do it right versus not is
like Leaps and Bounds because some
people are like dude I made content for
two years nothing happened and then they
spend like two weeks on Mr BEAST's team
and then they start cranking it's
because they just learned all the [__]
and so many of them are paradigms that
you thought to be true that weren't so
well I thought I'd eat every hour or I
was gonna gain weight you look for the
mentors to disprove the beliefs to show
you how reality is and what are the
right inputs the right way and then it's
just the time game